Air That's what I made, but I'm
running out of energy You're too small to maintain your body temperature
.
It's good, but it's high in calories,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I
've come to three towns of flowers, and
I'm full of nutrition  That's no good,
let them hover like they're throwing up and make them suck directly, but it's impossible with the bird wings we've been using up until now
.
It's true, but don't deny the way I look.
It flies by creating a swirl of air by moving
the  Not only that, but you'll also be able to fly backwards.
ーWhat
should I do if I hibernate? My
heart rate and body temperature drop only at night like I hibernate
.